auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die verstopften
das ist komisch dass das eine sache eine
passage in der pampa uruguays vier
monate nach dem chor die althaus auf und
davon ging kommt auch ehefrau susan im
neuen heim an
für ihr projekt muss das paar auf 14
quadratmeter zusammenrücken hochsaison
in kanada das modell aus den 60er jahren
bringt familie almeyda viel mehr arbeit
als erwartet
ihren wunsch nach mehr ruhe müssen die
auswanderer aus dem kanton zürich
zurückstellen und an der nordsee steht
der imbiss von sascha und bringt kunst
kurz vor der eröffnung bis das geschäft
mit fürsten und pommes frites angelaufen
ist bleiben noemi und timo bei ihrer
großmutter
[Musik]
im hotel von familie almeyda sind übers
wochenende alle zimmer ausgebucht
nicht ohne grund es ist oktoberfest für
einmal ist beatrice ohne ihren mann
josef unterwegs sie hat sich mit nachbar
charles und einer freundin verabredet
beatrice wie wissen was die
veranstaltung so besonders macht
[Musik]
das oktoberfest in thematisch ist das
größte seiner art im osten kanadas
aber lassen
zwei tage lang zelebrieren den menschen
aus der provinz nova scotia bayerische
bräuche
[Musik]
mal die haare schön macht irgendwo tätig
was ist endlich gebrochen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der nächste morgen zurück in den alltag
zurück ins hotel
die zimmer müssen für neue gäste wieder
hergerichtet werden doch eine der beiden
reinigungskräfte hat sich krankgemeldet
hat mit fisch und und seltenes goslars
war eine stufe bringen die arbeit es ist
fast wie einst in ihrem bett and
breakfast in total
so war ich eigentlich wollten die armee
das in kanada kürzer treten
aber das modell frau derzeit tag für tag
aufs neue
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an der nordsee im imbiss von familie
kunz ist alles bereit für die eröffnung
fast alles wieder auf schwierigkeiten
wer ohne punkte der job im imbiss ist
für die baselbieter 9
brigid eine gelernte krankenschwester
arbeitete teilzeit in einem
sportgeschäft sascha verkauft er als
vertreter signalisation 's technik die
ersten eigenen von fred neun monate
nachdem die auswanderer den imbiss in
den ferien entdeckt hatten
nach der rot- reh- darf natürlich nicht
fehlen
er hat seine ganze familie mitgebracht
samt eltern und großeltern
so oder so
jetzt schauen wir weiter weiter geht's
[Gelächter]
liga del frikadelle einfach mal so zum
test pause auf denen haben euro
verzeichnet und bürstadt und probiert
und macht und sehr kritisch gegenüber
von deiner produkt aber ich glaube es
zeigt dass das laufen braucht erwachsen
die ersten gäste sind schon mal
zufrieden
so darf der tag gerne weitergehen
[Musik]
zum gemeinsamen staat diensten leben
wollen rudi und zu sein althaus ein
bäumchen pflanzen das projekt gut dass
die zentren
ich glaube man muss danach am morgen mit
diesem bisschen nachlässig
zdf-zweiteiler sowie das ist natürlich
nicht der biologe
seit der ankunft in so wie vor zwei
tagen hat kategorie das bild kaum
verlassen
aus dem lieblichen emmental in die
fremde südamerikanischen pampa fünf
hektar land warten jetzt darauf erkundet
zu werden
ja ich habe für 50 mit 550 von ganz
vorne sicheren ort wo man sowohl an
kennt jetzt ganz anderen ort aber ich
glaube wirklich stressig finden
auch so sein muss sich erst eingewöhnen
ganz im gegensatz zu ehemann rudi für
ihn ist die schweiz und ganz weit weg
die letzten jahre hatte der gelernte bau
schreiner einen bürojob beim bund wieder
stufen ist ineffektiv nicht gross nach
[Musik]
kategorie geht es wie so seien sie
brauchen beide noch etwas zeit
[Musik]
früher nachmittag an der nordsee und
plötzlich ist die hafen terrasse voll
von fred für zwei euro 20 die currywurst
350 mit kleinen beträgen müssen zerstört
prix geht nun ihren lebensunterhalt
bestreiten
mindestens 100 wird der wollen sie am
ersten tag verkaufen
[Musik]
zwei würste und dann eine pommes
ja
einmal mehr spezial- und sex schicken
david körpers professional
29 10
[Musik]
rostock - mit nix
doch nix
mal
[Musik]
in kanada macht sich familie an meiler
ans nächste projekt heute wurden sie
einige reklametafeln für das motel
erneuern
rund 15 schilder hat der vorbesitzer
rund um den ort täter mappus aufgestellt
[Musik]
josef will das neue schild direkt auf
das alte schrauben
doch das ist gar nicht so einfach
auf diese art werbung können die all my
das auch im internetzeitalter nicht
verzichten
einen großen teil des geschäfts machen
sie mit gästen die ohne zu buchen direkt
vorbei kommen
ok
die krise
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann geht es weiter auf den bauernmarkt
von peter marcus die armee das wollen
sich so gut es geht ins dorfleben
integrieren
[Musik]
wie das geschäft ziemlich gut ein paar
monate erst lebt die familie in kanada
aber für sie ist jetzt schon klar sie
wollen bleiben
das ist aber das war nicht mit irgendwem
hinterhof europas mithalten kann einfach
sehr gut aus es braucht
[Musik]
der schacht ring aus beton ist für den
neuen brunnen
zusammen mit zu sein möchte ruhe die die
wasserpumpe verkleiden
die pousada in uruguay ist nicht ihr
erstes projekt schon das einfamilienhaus
im emmental hatten die beiden
eigenhändig gebaut
das eigene wasser zu haben war ihnen
schon beim kauf des landes wichtig die
fünf gästehäuser ein restaurant sowie
den swimmingpool wollen sie mit diesem
wasser versorgen
bisher trieb die bauarbeiten alleine
voran
eigentlich ist die holzverarbeitung sein
fachgebiet aber ruhe die ist einer der
sich zu helfen weiß
für die wasserinstallationen hat er
einen befreundeten spengler um rat
gefragt im internet recherchiert und
sich tricks bei den handwerkern die den
brunnen gebohrt haben abgeschaut
naja
[Musik]
von der krankenpflegerin zur ersten
hilfsarbeiterin so sein wird noch manche
gelegenheit haben in diese rolle
hineinzuwachsen
damit dehnte sich auch repressions
arbeit aber das ist der moment ist gut
aber nicht versuchen müssen wir das auch
nicht gut wenn die kühe machen was hast
du gut gemacht
[Musik]
abendstimmung auf glatte eins gut zehn
stunden standen bringt und sasha an der
fritteuse
wir haben keine guten ersten tag bevor
jetzt einmal abzocke noch dann viele
stunden
noch aber ist nicht schluss sie müssen
die grill küche reinigen
eineinhalb stunden putzen das gehört nun
zu den täglichen aufgaben
[Musik]
ja super ja was alles gut
michael sowie städte dieser drei aus dem
haus nicht haben
[Musik]
und dann kassensturz 662 euro haben sie
eingenommen
wir wissen was da in jonas doch auch
wirklich erreichen
und das ist nicht so leider
leiter betreut
[Musik]
jetzt muss nur noch das öl in der
friteuse erneuern
doch irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit dem
auslauf aber es war hatte immer noch das
ist komisch dass das nicht eskaliert wir
sehen jetzt nicht
[Musik]
der abfluss will einfach nicht
mit einlage
[Musik]
europa hat ein letzter versuch mit den
rat von oben
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite des großen teichs
läuft bisher alles nach plan
eineinhalb jahre gibt es sich für den
bau dann wollen die schweizer hier
zahlen der gäste beherbergen
als erstes gebäude will der 53-jährige
das wasch und werkstatt haus fertig
stellen
das neue heim der auswanderer liegt
unweit von colonia del sacramento
die stadt hat knapp 27.000 einwohner und
ist wegen ihrer historischen altstadt
ein touristenmagnet
susan hat sich mit auswanderungs
beraterin alex verabredet sie gibt tipps
wo sie in zukunft für den alltag
einkaufen kann
[Musik]
ihr kennt ja susan möchte für ruhe die
etwas besonderes kochen ein milanese
könnten wir machen
bei dieser gelegenheit kann so sahen
auch hier spanisch testen
in der schweiz hatte sie regelmäßig
privat lektionen genommen
die jenaer völlig vor was ich mit ein
und führt sie wirklich ausleben
du kommst auch ohne mich klar
nur ist halt bequemer wenn sie muss dann
muss ja das ist so und das hat die frage
wann sie lust hat ist zu müssen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
maradona ist nicht höhere risiken habe
rolle wie anbricht kam phau familie an
weiter erkundet in kanada ein
riesengroßes grundstück direkt vor ihrer
haustür beginnt die wildnis
es ist ein tag wie er schöner nicht sein
könnte stünde den allem haiders nicht
ein abschied bevor schon morgen fliegt
mutter beatrice zurück in die schweiz
[Musik]
jedes jahr im herbst wie sie alice kurz
debatten und auf märkten verkaufen
aber ich habe gut funktioniert
die zusätzliche einnahmequelle hat aber
auch eine kehrseite zehn wochen ist die
von der familie getrennt
[Musik]
beatrice und josef sind seit 23 jahren
ein paar und waren noch nie länger als
ein paar tage getrennt
die vertragssache schleswig ja ich hoffe
ich auch viel arbeit
willkommen sind
aber es macht die strom natürlich auch
das fräulein ich auch so
[Musik]
für jeden gartenzwerg
tag 10 an küsten imbiss für einmal
schließen die kunst ins frühe denn
endlich kommen auch die kinder nach
dorum sechs wochen haben sascha und
prägt ihre kinder nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ja danke
nur noch ein paar minuten dann kommen
thema und noemi am bahnhof in
bremerhaven an
[Musik]
noemi und timo sind vor mehr als zehn
stunden mit ihrer großmutter susan im
baselbiet aufgebrochen
eine reise durch ganz deutschland
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
soziale sache
oh mein gott
im neuen heim in dorum erwartet noemi
ein frisch renoviertes zimmer zu schwach
auch timo hat neue möbel bekommen
märz 2009 ist so ganz haben
aber schön endlich wieder vereint
[Musik]
fehlt nur noch der große sohn kevin
feierabend in uruguay
gut zehn stunden schuften der
auswanderer rudi auf der baustelle
ehefrau susan hat etwas früher schluss
gemacht und bereitet das nacht vor aus
einem sieben zimmer haus in einen
wohncontainer für ihren traum mit der
pousada nehmen die beiden einiges in
kauf
[Gelächter]
nach 30 jahren beziehung stürzen sich
rudi und susann noch einmal ins
abenteuer in der weite der pampa sehen
sie sich so nahe wie schon lange nicht
mehr den doblo
vielleicht ist die sache eigentlich zu
wenig
[Musik]
das ist effektiv zu ja wirklich mehr
und für die ganze familie
therapie gemacht der pianist wird eine
professionelle hier auf zwei minuten
zurück und hätte damit leben retten
ich sage nicht einmal die globalisierung
stellt sich die leute gerade mit hier
[Musik]
gut da
klasse
[Musik]
heute reist beatrix ab dem 8 jährigen
robin fällt es besonders schwer seiner
mama und bei zu sagen
ja ich habe dieses jahr wieder da und
dann wird ja dann charakteristisches
aroma ich komme ja das ist eine tolle
chance gering
[Musik]
nur noch vier stunden dann setzt
beatrice im flieger in die schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an der nordsee richtet sich preetz
mutter in ihrer neuen drei zimmer
wohnung ein
ohne die enkelin der schweiz zu bleiben
wollte sich die 70 jährige susan gar
nicht erst vorstellen sehr aktiv und
kinderwagen tändelei oder berge und den
schulen wieder rauf ort wird das glaube
ich ist schwierig für windhund hat an
jan o und dann habe ich zumindest meine
vorgabe die firma mit der lupe wieder
zusammen wohnt im ersten stock
schwiegersohn sascha und doch der ball
geht mit den kindern im erdgeschoss
ehrlich schwerer krankheiten untersuchen
aber das ist man sich auf bis soll das
muss auch carina durch das ächten
klaus da jetzt ein bisschen kino
geheiratet hat sich das halbzeitfazit 12
ja ich glaube das leben schwer
kaum sind die kinder da müssen sasha und
prägt schon wieder weg der imbiss wartet
die arbeit fordert ihnen einiges ab bis
zum saisonende in drei monaten haben sie
keinen tag frei es kann nicht
funktionieren
womöglich kommt er oft konnte dann kann
ich in schönebeck ihren da kommt es auf
einen hinteren
so
am flughafen in halifax heißt es
abschied nehmen
[Musik]
sie unterhalten die zwei mal die schöne
der wirkstoff gut
[Musik]
lange
in der nächsten folge startet beatrix in
der schweiz mit dem verkauf ihre gutes
leben die zeit allein in kanada fordert
ehemann josef mehr als gedacht
an der nordsee kommt großmutter susan
zum ersten mal an den imbiss- und wird
gleich eingespannt und tochter noemi
muss sich im training im neuen
cheerleading verein bewähren
in uruguay erfüllen sich rudi und susann
einen lang gehegten wunsch
aber das leben auf der baustelle
hinterlässt bereits erste spuren
[Musik]
muss ich die gerne wieder mit träumen
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge